Unreal Engine 5 has a very powerful set of modeling tools that can be accessed right
inside of the editor that allow you to not only create messages inside of the engine,
but also edit existing messages.
And this is fantastic if you ever need to do something like reset a pivot or you want
to maybe fix a minor detail or adjust something in a slight way.
You don't have to go back to your digital content creation tool.
You can do it right from within the engine.
Let's pop over to the editor now and take a quick look at these tools.
So to access the tools, I come up here to my selection and then I come down to my modeling.
Now I can use the modeling mode with a pre-selected static mesh or I can create a static mesh
to model from.
So in this instance, I'm just going to create a box here and then once I have that, I'm
going to say accept.
With that done, I'm now going to go over to my modeling mode here, go to my Poly Group
edit and this is going to allow me to do things like extrude this face.
And then I can also move things around and rotate as I would in any other DCC.
And you can see here I have a number of different options that I can do.
For example, I could come here and select each one of these edges and then do something
like a bevel.
So in accept that action.
And then once I'm all done with everything I can do except and there we go.
Here's my newly modeled mesh, although it's not the world's greatest mesh, but I did model
it right inside of the editor.
Notice that I also have things like baking of UVs.
I can voxelize my mesh in case I'm making something very complex and I want to cut down
on geometry or maybe I just want to wrap it inside of another mesh for some reason to
get that resulting geometry and do something else with it.
There's a bunch of things here that go from simplifying our meshes so that maybe we bring
in a mesh that is very high poly and we want to simplify it.
We can do that right within this tool set.
So this is a very, very powerful tool set modeling mode and it can do much, much more
than just model.
And I highly suggest that everybody dig into it to find out all of its benefits for any
of the projects you're working on.